I would like to introduce you to
Christian Grey Oh No we started this
book club to stimulate our minds from
what I hear this book is quite
stimulating this has been I think such a
great year for females in film females
in the lead but also just in terms of
the box office people are responding so
there's sort of your thoughts on that
and why is this the perfect time for
this film couldn't agree with you more
it's the year of the woman and women are
out front and a lot of big hit movies
and it's really important and exciting
and it means that there'll be more
movies that have women in the leads how
is this different than we've seen you
before
like as a character how are these
characters different I think it's
shocking to see for women our age in a
movie that are the leads in a movie that
aren't playing somebody's mother or
somebody's crazy and the film cares
about these friendships and about these
characters and that doesn't happen very
often and it kind of reminds people that
if you're lucky enough that your life is
long enough there are lots of stories to
tell about that life everybody remembers
their first kiss how about I tell you
about my best kiss maybe that hasn't
happened yet one of the themes about
this film is about getting your feeling
your mojo and if maybe you've lost that
feeling how do you how do you keep your
mojo going sleep enough I have mojo but
if I she has more mojo than in each get
more sleep than anybody friends and and
not getting overextended is so in a way
what Jane said just to know when were
your limits oh and if I start losing my
mojo
even if I've had enough sleep
girlfriends always put it back in me
since when do you eat ice cream I got a
brain freeze here give that to a
professionai god
[Music]
[Music]